tout ce qu'on a pour 10 euros ça
carrefour je vais te dire tu les as par
l'épidémie de coronavirus a changé au
moins en partie la manière dont certains
français achètent leurs produits
alimentaires pour certains consommateurs
de l'agglomération lyonnaise fini les
supermarchés les grandes surfaces face à
la décision du gouvernement d'interdire
les marchés couverts ou non des
organisations des producteurs et des
clients s'organise pour faire vivre les
circuits courts c'est le cas de ces
étudiants qui oeuvrent au sein de la
distrib des gros colis une amap
association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne
moi je trouve quasiment que des
avantages à la map et je suis étonné
qu'il ait pas plus de gens qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient abonnés aux amap
peut-être que le contexte actuel va
faire que les gens vont redécouvrir
simplement le bon sens c'est que faire
travailler un agriculteur et manger des
bons produits
ça a du sens et c'est bon pour tout le
monde c'est gagnant gagnant pour fournir
cette clientèle les producteurs doivent
s'organiser
hervé michel agriculteurs rhodanien est
au rendez vous avec ses paniers destinés
à nourrir deux personnes pendant une
semaine
et comme sa ferme et à côté de lyon sa
distribution n'est pas impactée par les
restrictions duo coronavirus tout ce que
j'aime c'est bien d'autres orientations
c'est tout c'est tous les légumes de
saison riche en échanges
les chants d'une semaine sur l'autre
mais rarement la même chose d'une
semaine à part la salade cette amap
lyonnaise a obtenu auprès de la
préfecture un permis de distribution en
plein air mais les membres de
l'association la distrib des gros colis
doivent garantir le respect des gestes
barrières distance de sécurité d'au
moins un mètre port de gants et de
masques limitation de personnes ayant
accès au panier et production locale lé
peloton ce qui pour ses formes
d'associations pour moi je pense que ça
va être le futur peut-être c'est
peut-être ça qui va nous donner en fait
au niveau 2 on va dire que ces crises
qu'on a vues multiples au delà de la
crise du coronavirus exploitants
agricoles artisans et clients sont
convaincus que les circuits courts ont
de beaux jours devant eux
[Applaudissements]